the David Pakman show subreddit is truly one
of the best places on the internet. I would
argue for sensible, sober, and respectful
political discussions. More than 15,000 of
our viewers and listeners are now subscribed@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit and I want to look at a couple
of posts that I noticed that are interesting.
One is from a user called bad smash four,
who says, do David's videos get titled in
such a way as to specifically attract right-wingers?
I really disliked the way David's videos are
titled. I always have. They're always very
click baity. They don't represent what David
has to offer as an analyst. Um, here's the
thing, and he says, do, uh, am I deliberately
tiding the titling videos this way to attract
right wingers? And if so, that that would
actually, uh, be a respectful thing to do.
Listen, we do. I, I think that the entire
YouTube titling a status quo is basically
a game. And we approach it satirically, which
is we will make satirical titles that are
not necessarily inaccurate, but they are satirically
sensational. So, you know, when I enter, when
I'm interviewed on some other show, we will
upload it. As, you know, David destroyed by
facts and logic.
It's satire because there's a contingent of
the right that loves to talk about how all
these right-wingers, like Ben Shapiro are
destroying lefties with facts and logic. Like
it's not serious. It's not specifically to
attract a particular audience. It's just playing
around with internet memes and that's it.
I wouldn't read too much more into it and
remember that in the end the title is just
a title. The bulk of what we're doing is really
the content. And as long as we're not being,
you know, um, uh, truly deceptive. You know,
these are basically meme titles and jokes
and satire or whatever. And I get, not everybody
might get it, but I feel pretty good about
the titles that we're using. And, uh, you
know, we're, we're doing what we can with
YouTube metadata to get the biggest possible
audience cause that's the important thing.
Um, another user LBJs PNS, interesting says
complains Monday's show had zero mention of
Bernie's rally.
David complains about losing viewership when
he talks about the polls. However, I think
his pro Warren biases coming out. Whenever
Warren does anything in the polls, he's all
over it. Like white on rice. Bernie holds
the largest rally of this political season
and crickets and I actually pointed out we
don't really cover rallies like we just, we
just don't cover rallies. If something noteworthy
happens at a rally, like for example the attempted
identity politics game that our reporter tried
to playing with AOC and Bernie at that rally,
we covered that but this is one of those places
where if all you have is a hammer, everything
looks like a nail. If all you want to see
is some kind of anti Bernie pro Warren bias
on the program, you will find both the coverage
of things and the lack of coverage of things
to feed that narrative when the truth is we
just don't cover that our rally took place.
What we cover is whether interesting things
are said at a rally that warrant analysis
if unusual things take place and therefore
we covered yesterday. In the context of mentioning
this was I believe the biggest rally of the
political season. We covered the content of
an interview that took place. That's it. Don't
read more into things than than what is actually
warranted by the facts. Join the discussion@thedavidpakmanshowsubredditdavidpakman.com
slash R E. D. D. I. T